the Federal Bureau of Investigation or
FBI is the National Intelligence and
Security Service of the United States
founded in July 26 1908 the FBI was
constitutionalized by the u.s. general
attorney a small group of newly
qualified federal investigators would
report directly to the chief examiner at
the Department of Justice one year later
the office of the chief examiner was
renamed to the Bureau of Investigation
and in 1935 became the Federal Bureau of
Investigation
the FBI's primary goal is to defend and
protect the United States essentially
working as a counterterrorism
counterintelligence in criminal
investigation agency the FBI's special
weapons and tactics officers otherwise
known as SWAT are highly specialized
agents trained in intervention
techniques and high-risk events such as
hostage and terrorist attacks
SWAT teams are considered incredibly
versatile and can be used in various
types of operations so naturally after
the reactivation of team Rambo in 2015
for FBI SWAT agents were recruited to to
their high level of expertise in the
fight against global terrorism these
special agents are codenamed Ashe
thermite castle and pulse
[Music]
you
when I was little myself to taught me
that silence was a woman's best garment
but I have to admit I never really took
her advice to heart
Eliza Cohen codenamed Ashe is an
attacking operator and team rainbow
raised in Israel her mother is a
renowned Jewish political activist and
professor and her father is a
Palestinian professor and Middle Eastern
Studies along with Hebrew she's fluent
in English Arabic French and Greek
excelling in mathematics and physics she
under degree and structural engineering
at tel aviv university after enlisting
in the Israeli Defense Force Ashe
underwent a rigorous training for 22
months in the elite air force unit where
she served for five years military
service acted as an escape from family
tension and appealed to her ordered and
focused personality she welcomed the
high-risk high-reward situations issues
a quick thinker and a regressive style
put her in advantage later Ashe
transferred to the FBI through an
international law enforcement exchange
program and using a qualifications and
experience was able to develop
specialized equipment and advanced
demolition techniques she prefers not to
discuss her personal life with others
and seems to hold some sort of
resentment from her past this may be why
she is so cautious and does not have too
many close friends
who colleagues best describers intents
maybe a little too serious and she loves
being right often during debrief she'll
dwell on a performance with an extremely
over critical persona it's not only
exhausting I don't mean to well being
but it can also be draining on her team
what she needs to realize as these
situations require teamwork and she must
learn to trust your team to share the
load rather than taking it all on
herself she is used to her knowledge of
explosives and demolitions to create a
modified grenade launcher with the m120
trend developed as a portable weapon
that's similar to other explosive
breaching tools used by American and
Israeli Armed Forces the m120 crane is
capable of breaking through doors
without the need of destroying hinges or
locks it fires a devastating great round
from a distance which automatically
dissipates after borrowing into nearly
any kind of barricade when you mix fuel
metal oxide and metal powder in just the
right way it burns at 2,000 degrees
Celsius but enough to cut through nearly
any barrier known to man
throw some c4 into the mix and you've
got one hell of accommodation Jordan
Trace codenamed thermite is an attacking
operator and team rainbow they might
join the court straight out of high
school making them a fourth-generation
Marine following his first tour of Iraq
he obtained enough experience to
volunteer as an explosive ordnance
disposal technician after a second tour
of Iraq they might return to the u.s.
enrolled at Texas A&M University and
earned a Bachelor of Science and
chemistry
he brought his experiences and skills to
the FBI where he spent four years as a
field agent with the hazardous materials
response unit seeking more variation
thermite transferred to the FBI SWAT
where he excelled at developing new
barricade protocols
he was then recruited to rainbow where
he is shown further interest in research
and development
fermer is disciplined and orderly and
yet oddly enough still enjoys a good
practical joke and oftentimes can come
across as a bit of a class clown he is
well liked by the others he is excellent
communication when he chooses to use it
he also demonstrates a lot of strong and
clever leadership skills unfortunately
he often plows ahead without thought
however there's a lot going on behind
his smile and he needs to learn how to
balance his work and private life
separately who might recently lost his
sister to cancer and a few years prior
his mother passed away with their
passing he has struggled to keep his
emotions in check and to channel his
thoughts and energy which is something
he's not accustomed to because of this
he uses humor as a smokescreen to hide
his deep underlying grief that he is yet
to come to terms with fortunately he
doesn't show any obvious signs of stress
and instead chooses to channel as
negative energy into something positive
like his research and development lab
however he does need to learn how to
step away from his role as an operator
from time to time
though Mac comes equipped with a unique
exothermic breach charge gadget that can
easily melt through tough walls and
barricades developed by FBI SWAT
engineers the brimstone was designed to
breach reinforced locations utilizing a
compact and portable explosive load that
can deliver maximum destruction firstly
the charge burns through the barrier
then detonates with the use of c4
[Music]
damages miles Campbell codenamed Castle
is a defending operator and team member
he graduated from California State
University with a bachelor's degree in
science and criminal justice
he then promptly joined the Los Angeles
Police Department after five years on
the job he was assigned to the LAPD SWAT
where he excelled and after three years
transferred to the FBI he spent two
years as an FBI field agent and not long
after his career took its natural
progression and he was assigned to the
FBI SWAT team Castle is generally known
as a nice easygoing guy and among the
other rainbow operators is referred to
as Papa Bear or the diplomat and is
considered to be the team's social glue
this and his openness means that Cassel
can be grouped with any member of Team
Rambo in the field
with his exceptional knack for putting
people at ease he always appears to be
comfortable regardless of the situation
his sense of fair play is clear both in
his personal and professional life his
perception of his job is that he is
there to protect those who can't protect
themselves
he is constantly striving to make others
around him feel safe and are taken care
of especially those closest to him
the andhe sense of justice he is a
desire to transform things for the
better this is what motivates him
Cassel is also a hopeful person and
believes in the potential of people all
people and wants to be the agent of
change his parents who have been married
for 42 years are still madly in love
they are playfully loyal and kind to
each other and this is the sort of
positive energy that he tries to emulate
with others in fact he's so concerned
for others that he often times may be
overlooking his own needs
castles special skill set focus around
the defensive tactics and intelligence
he has a deep appreciation for other
cultures and in his spare time studies
languages he is proficient in Spanish
Latin and Korean in his earlier years
while working with the FBI SWAT castle
found himself in the middle of a hostage
extraction where he became cornered in a
small Bell building utilizing what was
available to him he made a crude
blockade from a discarded blanket and a
staple gun he found in the shed this
allowed him to limit the line of sight
to enemy snipers and remain concealed
until backup arrived this experience
inspired the creation of the UTP one
universal tactical panel a lightweight
barricade that has been successfully
utilized in FBI SWAT operations since
its implementation in 2013
in a life-threatening situation the
average person's heartbeat can be
upwards of 175 beats per minute but the
well-trained tango is able to stay cool
and keep calm
there are rates can be 70 to 100 beats
per minute
but by the time I'm done that number
goes down to zero
Jaka strata codenamed pulse is a
defending operator and tim rambow
born on Seymour Johnson Air Force Base
pulse was raised on bases across the US
and internationally in Germany Turkey
and Japan his father was a pilot and his
mother was a classified senior
intelligence officer Pulse demonstrated
brilliance for science at an early age
and was quickly moved into an advanced
curriculum as a result of the constant
relocation from base to base bas was
fascinated by the microscopic variances
that comprise identity he became adept
at recognizing facial expressions and
depicting a person's history based on
their speech patterns and physical
attributes his focus on forensic science
and biochemistry made him the perfect
effect for the biometrics program in the
FBI which he joined as the youngest
intern he secured a role as an agent and
was soon recruited into SWAT working
both in the field and FBI lab pulses
high emotional intelligence led him to
join the FBI's hostage rescue team wery
excelled at crisis management and
negotiation tactics his knowledge of
behavioral biometrics led him to the
creation of the cardiac sensor along
with several other prototypes which he
continues to refine during operations
pulse keeps his cool and consistently
maintained sound judgment yet at the
same time you'd struggle to find anyone
with as much positive energy and
enthusiasm he is a range of interests
from biology to fighter jets to scuba
diving he often jokes off becoming an
astronaut he is excited by the idea of
exploration and the concept of alien
life-forms pulses fascination with
biology and chemistry started when he
was a child it was his mother that first
noticed how good he was of
deconstructing others she encouraged
free thinking and let him decide the
path of his academic studies life is a
sense of adventure and pulse is ready to
grasp it all but even under the most
extreme conditions pulse puts his team
first naturally they all speak very
highly of him pulse says it's the
caliber of his teammates that makes him
so dedicated
while working on the FBI biometrics
program pulse developed a portable
device capable of tracking a suspect's
blood flow and heartbeat
the portable cardiac sensor proved a
useful non-invasive interrogation tool
as the operator was able to monitor the
stress level of the suspects and
reliably determine their truthfulness
the since was then equipped with a
higher resolution screen and programmed
to determine the relative distance of
the targets the modified cardiac sensor
was successfully implemented into the
FBI SWAT teams surveillance
countermeasures with sniper spotters and
negotiators have effectively used their
device to locate hostiles behind cover
or from a secure location and that about
sums it up I'll continue in my mission
of picking up as much as I possibly can
of the stories of Rainbow six siege and
eventually I can start to speculate on
the possible crossovers between this and
the other tom clancy games our cover
thank you again to dray Gnaeus for
helping me out with this title where
admittedly
I'm not as strong and a huge special
thank you to Harding Stephenson who
provided me with a hell of a lot of
information regarding the AR succeed
story we're talking hundreds of images
anyway if you've made it this far please
give kudos to hiding and reneus in the
comments and thank you very much for
watching I'll catch you in the next one
Cheers
[Music]
[Music]